que marie pierre martin elle est
infirmière aux urgences de l'hôpital
necker une chargée de communication du
collectif inter urgence marie pierre
martin bonsoir merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors le plan
blanc a donc été déclenché à paris en
ile-de-france tension aussi dans
d'autres hôpitaux français comment vous
préparer à cette nouvelle marée annoncé
l'hôpital va-t-il tenir
on se prépare on se prépare comme on
peut l'hôpital va-t-il tenir vous selon
sein d'une personne n'y a déjà pas tenu
la première fois donc on verra bien
l'hôpital il faut savoir que c'était
intentions bien avant le coz id c'était
attention bien avant l'on n'a pas eu les
changements dont on avait besoin avec le
ségur les syndicats signataires ont pas
du tout pris en compte les besoins du
terrain donc on se retrouve dans une
situation où malgré le ségur on a daily
qui continuent de fermer sur le terrain
on a des on a des soignants qui sont
épuisés qu'ils étaient épuisés déjà
avant qu'ils le sont encore plus
on n'a pas de reconnaissance on n'a pas
eu tout ce qu'on avait besoin c'est bien
gentil de nous dire qu'on au soutien
mais à côté de ça quand on vient voir et
qu'on dit qu'on a des réels problèmes
sur le terrain nous aident pas on n'a
pas les réponses qu'on a besoin
donc non la crise sanitaire nous a pas
aidé du tout être pas du tout parce que
marie pierre martin des accords du ségur
de la santé promettait des mesures comme
des embauches avec un montant de plus de
8 milliards d'euros 1
donc ça veut dire que dans les faits
aujourd'hui vous n'observez rien à nant
dans les embauches elle sent pas là on
continue à avoir des démissions en
plaine enfin on continue à avoir des
démissions en masse à avoir des gens qui
quittent l'hôpital qui semble qu'ils
s'en vont c'est assez impressionnant on
continue à avoir vraiment les gens
quittent l'hôpital tout ça on a des
démissions les fermetures de lits et les
conditions de travail sont de pire en
pire donc c'est très compliqué alors
avec le plan blanc des interventions
vont êtres vont devoir être déprogrammée
finalement nous voilà au même niveau que
durant le confinement mais c'est même
encore pire parce qu'en fait pendant
confinement on n'avait pas les épidémies
saisonnières là on arrive en plein
dedans on a
la grippe on à la gastro on allait les
bons piaule it tous les renforts qui
avait été qui sont venus en région
parisienne dans le grand est
il faut savoir que là on les aura pas
ils seront pas là la pédiatrie pourra
pas dépanner que ce soit en matériel ou
que ce soit en personnel parce qu'il ya
l'épidémie de bronchiolite qui est
arrivé les équipes les équipes sont déjà
à bout c'est déjà une période qui est
très tendue pour l'hôpital l'hiver et
donc avec le co vide ça va pas
s'améliorer alors olivier verrons ce
soir à réitérer un son soutien au
personnel soignant
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
a qualifié votre profession
d'exceptionnel rappelant lui avoir été
touchées par la maladie
comment est-ce que vous recevez ces mots
d'encouragement ce soir c'est bien c'est
très gentil de nous soutenir
maintenant si quand on est en grève
depuis 18 mois et qu'on dit qu'il ya des
choses qui vont pas qu'on en a marre de
voir des patients qui passent des jours
entiers sur des brancards qu'il ya des
hospitalisations brancards que l'hôpital
ne tient plus que l'hôpital est en
tension qu'on est en train de nous
prendre ma langue ça en charge et en
soins la population française quand ça
fait 18 mois qu'on dit tout ça et qu'au
final il faut une crise sanitaire pour
comprendre que notre soutien on aimerait
bien avoir des mesures à la hauteur des
besoins de la population en santé
alors depuis la première vague vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure un de nombreux
soignants ont quitté leurs fonctions
qu'est ce que ça révèle au fond un
épuisement généralisé ou ou davantage d'
un écoeurement bas les deux je pense en
tout cas un les soignants sont épuisés
ça c'est une chose qui est claire quand
on a des collègues qui raconte que ils
ont plus envie de voir les patients
mourir sur des brancards c'est une
réalité c'est ce qui s'est passé pendant
la première vague
c'est ce qui se passait déjà avant bien
avant le coup vide on avait déjà des
gens qui passaient 48 heures sur un
brancard aux urgences parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de place parce qu'on ferme des
lits parce qu'il ya déjà des soignants
qui s'en vont parce que la charge de
travail explosé parce qu'on n'a pas les
moyens et le temps de prendre soin aux
patients correctement alors vous appelé
à une nouvelle manifestation jeu sera le
15 octobre
quel sera le mot d'ordre ce sera le mot
d'ordre c'est la stap à l'hémorragie et
ses 2
2ce continuer à se battre pour avoir un
système de santé tels qu on aimerait
qu'ils soient et qu'ils puissent prendre
en charge la population française de
manière correcte et de manière humaine
faite pour conclure cette dernière
question entendue le président de la
république emmanuel macron dire que ce
n'était pas forcément une question de
moyens mais plus une question
d'organisation
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez abbas et
c'est très bien c'est ce qu'on a dit
depuis 18 mois et on montre bien que
c'est pas ça c'était une question
d'organisation local ça ferait longtemps
que les hôpitaux ne seraient pas tous
d'accord là on est tous d'accord on
parle tous de la même voix on est tous
sur le même fait qu' il manque de lits
en manque de personnel on manque de
moyens on a besoin de moyens il faut
débloquer des moyens pour l'hôpital
sinon on se retrouve dans une situation
catastrophique comme on a pu la
connaître en mars et comme arrive prend
pas probablement dans les moyens merci
beaucoup marie pierre martin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes infirmière aux urgences de
l'hôpital necker est chargé de
communication du collectif interurbain
ans